jusqu'au 30 septembre le musée
d'archéologie nationale de saint germain
en laye propose des visites de ses toits
animée par un guide
une manière pour cet ancien château
royal de dévoiler certaines parties s'y
cacher au public
c'est une visite à ces demandes et et ça
fait on va dire quinze à vingt ans qu'on
l'ait fait c'est une manière de prendre
un peu de hauteur vis-à-vis du monument
ça permettrait un goût même promenade
qui permet de voir aussi tout le paysage
alentour pour monter sur les toits
il faut déjà grave y'a les cent trente
et une marche mais une fois l'effort
accompli on découvre un panorama
exceptionnel sur la vallée de la seine
puis guidé par un conférencier
on se promène sur les toits tout en
apprenant sur l'histoire et
l'architecturé imposé par les différents
rois de france
une visite que n'est pas près d'oublier
ce visiteur venu de nantes
notre fils habite sur paris et on vient
tous les gens et tous les gens visitent
deux ou trois photos qui autour de paris
comme avant-hier on était aux invalides
où on a vu la nuit des invalides où
justement il remettre toute l'histoire
de france de soissons bat des rois
francs jusqu'à la république ici c'était
aussi une suite quelque part entre la
royauté et l'art et la république
les visites sont possibles de l'âge de
13 ans et dure environ une heure elles
se déroulent tous les lundis jeudis et
vendredis